voilà pour les réfugiés en pologne
gauthier rybinski toujours avec moi en
plateau gauthier on l'a vu c'est énorme
élan de solidarité de la pologne à
l'égard des ukrainiens leurs voisins
c'est très intéressant parce que
évidemment c'est à l'honneur de la
pologne mais c'est quelque chose qui
nous apprend à quoi sert la paix à quoi
a servi l'occident en deux mots pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale entre la
pologne et les nationalistes ukrainiens
il y a eu des combats terribles et
surtout des exécutions commises par ces
nationalistes ukrainiens qui ont tué des
polonais des polonais juifs des polonais
non juifs des tziganes parce qu'ils
étaient les auxiliaires du régime nazi
que fait l'histoire quand on la maîtrise
quand on peut l'étudier elle apprend que
ces choses-là se dépassent dans le
présent et dans le temps qui passe et
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui explique que la
pologne ne soit pas enragé contre les
ukrainiens parce que ce temps a passé et
qu'on sait pardonner et consentants la
vision qu'un de l'histoire vladimir
poutine c'est exactement l'inversé de
fossilisés l'histoire fossilise à
l'histoire comme elle s'est produite il
ya 200 ans 300 400 ans ou 75 ans et donc
de ne jamais permettre le la possibilité
la résilience comme on dit la
possibilité de surmonter une histoire
c'est très très instructif il faut pas
oublier ça encore une fois entre la
pologne et l'ukraine il ya 75 ans
c'était quelque chose de dramatique ça
ne l'est plus aujourd'hui grâce à la à
l'éveil des consciences et à la vie à
l'histoire et à des milliers
d'ukrainiens d'ailleurs qui vivent en
pologne six bureaux y travailler
notamment bien ça moi avec vous gagnez
peut-être plus largement sur la que
cette vague de réfugiés ukrainien qui
pour l'instant que déferle donc on l'a
vu sur la peau l'homme et sur les autres
pays frontalier de l'ukraine
comment plus largement l'europe les pays
européens vont réagir selon goût à cet
afflux de réfugiés ukrainien quelle va
être l'attitude de l'europe
il y a un impératif qui est cet
impératif d'accueil il y a quelque chose
que nous ne devons pas oublier non plus
et là ça s'adresse entre autres la
pologne vous souvenez qu'il y à toujours
à la frontière entre la biélorussie la
pologne des réfugiés afghans il ne
s'agit pas de les oublier non seulement
parce que ce sont des êtres humains mais
parce que ce sont eux aussi des victimes
de la lâcheté de l'occident et qu'il ne
s'agit pas justement de faire un tri
entre ceux qui seraient le slave blanc
et européens est ce qu'ils ne sont pas
donc là il va falloir être très vigilant
là dessus et de faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas ces refus d'accueil qui ne
serait dû encore une fois qu'à notre
ignorance et à notre bêtise et ça je ne
suis pas malheureusement en mesure de
vous dire que ça ne se produira pas donc
ça c'est important un dernier point dans
le côté civil de la chose sur lequel
nous importer insisté qui est capital
vous savez qu'il y à des russes ou des
russophones qui vivent dans l'union
européenne royaume uni en france pour ne
prendre que ces deux pays ce qu'on me
rapporte aujourd'hui c'est par exemple
que des chauffeurs de taxi anglais à
londres refuse de prendre des
russophones des russes dans leur taxi on
me rapporte qu'au musée d'orsay à paris
des guides russe ou russophone sont
insultés par la population ça c'est
exactement du poutinisme poutine
considère la race l'ethnie considère le
sens et nous nous ferions pareil ça veut
dire que nous serions des auxiliaires de
poutine a d'autres à notre petit niveau
c'est inadmissible
ayant toujours en tête et nous le ferons
à chaque fois qu'il y aura des images
disponibles ce que font les russes
qu'ils manifestent contre cette guerre
ils ont un cran extraordinaire et
risquent beaucoup c'est cela aussi qu'il
faut aider et célébrer et donc soyons
vigilants je réponds à votre question en
fin de compte soyons vigilants dans
l'accueil de ces réfugiés sur le fait
qu'à la fois ce sont des êtres humains
et qu'ils sont le miroir de nos échecs
et de nos lâchetés merci beaucoup
gauthier